this is the story of how a virus we
didn't even know existed three months
ago has changed the way we live covered
19 has impacted life everywhere for
billions of people and it started here
in China in the city of Wuhan this was
the local train station at the time of
Chinese New Year it was busy enough but
people were staying away those who had
traveled or worried I'm sending my
nephew back to Beijing I'm his aunt we
plan to spend Chinese New Year here in
Wuhan that the situation here is not
good I tried to stay indoors as much as
possible try to avoid coming places like
this where there's lots of virus if I do
go out I wear a mask at the local
hospital they were refusing all patients
except those suspected of having the
virus they were dealing with the initial
outbreak this food market was pointed to
as the source of that outbreak it was
said that illegal wildlife was being
sold here on the streets of Wuhan there
was a heavy official presence as they
tried to contain the virus all wildlife
and poultry was banned and traveled from
the city was restricted before a total
lockdown was put in place
Wuhan became the first city in the world
to be sealed off roads were closed
trains were stopped and flights were
canceled a city of 11 million people was
effectively quarantined
people did rush to beat the cutoff there
were soldiers with thermometers at the
ready on the way out those who had fled
spoke of their concern yes I am worried
it said the city will be closed I need
to go back to work after Chinese New
Year but I don't know when the shutdown
will stop so I decided to leave early I
think what the government does is right
it should have done it earlier after all
this is a national adversity for us the
epidemic needs to be controlled and
restrained into a certain scale I saw it
in the news it was everywhere in the
news no one can get out after 10 a.m.
I felt the situation was indeed quite
serious we had planned to go back today
anyway so he wanted to see if we could
go earlier but this was to become a
crisis that would stretch far beyond
Wuhan and far beyond China all
passengers from Wuhan to the UK were
supposed to be screened on landing but
that was not the case for this man
completely an only normal aside from the
fact everybody's wearing long masks
they're normal and we got a leaflet as
we landed just like a if you have any
symptoms
there isn't been a virus please contact
us however that was all in English or in
Chinese the city where the mystery virus
first emerged had to cope in isolation
face masks began to rapidly sellout
across China as news of this virus
spread that now the masks are sold out
for days already like this morning just
within about one hour we had a dozen
people coming in to ask if we have masks
those busy just now and I forgot about
the masks but I should really wear it
news of the outbreak traveled quickly we
began to learn more about this worrying
new virus this is the Wuhan novel
coronavirus now coronaviruses are a
large family of viruses that can cause
illness ranging from the common cold to
more severe outbreaks such as Middle
East respiratory syndrome MERS and
severe acute respiratory syndrome known
as SARS now this strain called 20-19
novel coronavirus or n cough has not
previously been identified in humans so
there's no vaccine humans have no
immunity and the virus is able to mutate
making it hard to control
within days cases of the virus were
reported in other countries in the Far
East in Japan masked commuters staggered
their journeys to work to avoid crowds
schools shut from most of March many
offices temporarily closed employees
like taki or encouraged to work from
home I'm very worrying about the coroner
virus so I'm working from home and I'm
also putting masks and have a sanitizer
and try to not go into the crowded place
and avoid him to train so for so long
the Diamond Princess cruise ship was
forced to dock at Yokohama and stay
there after a man who disembarked in
Hong Kong was found to have the virus
more than 600 people on board also
tested positive first it was one of the
largest cluster of cases outside of
China after 17 days in quarantine some
of the passengers were able to head for
home Alan and Vanessa Sanford hadn't
left their room for a fortnight I think
I might struggle a bit more with this
second lot of 13 days what's worrying
you well just that you can't get on with
your life he used everything's on hold
and you also feel but I've got this
certificate that says I'm negative for
the virus and nobody on the aircraft is
going to be anything other than negative
for the virus it just seems excessive
but I do understand as well people are
nervous about having people back in the
country and when they got back to
England a further period in quarantine
on the world awaited them this was the
advice they were given by one man who
had stayed there after getting home from
Wuhan
I won't lie you know it is going to be
boring at times but you know if
you can sort of interact with others a
little bit and you know use the
entertainment systems that you have the
time should pass pretty quickly while
the Olympic Games are still going ahead
japan's Prime Minister requested that
other big events be postponed fewer
people means less chance of potentially
deadly clusters but hundreds of
infections were confirmed anyway and
fear started hitting Japanese businesses
visitor numbers dropped quickly these
days we don't have a lot of people from
United States or England or Europe of
course so we are just worried if we can
get their tourists it didn't take long
for this virus to move out of the Far
East
and much further afield at the end of
January
Italy detected and isolated its first
two cases both were Chinese tourists
prime minister Giuseppe Conte
immediately declared a state of
emergency for six months and Italy
became the first country in the world to
block flights from China but economic or
portability without the economic impact
could be very strong at this moment we
can calculate that there will be a
negative economic impact but we're not
able to predict how it is going to be
because we don't know yet the
containment effect of the
countermeasures that we adopted but by
early March the country had the second
highest number of infections outside
China and that was despite an initial
lockdown that saw 10 towns in northern
Italy put into isolation this was the
area where Europe's outbreak seems to
have started people needed special
permission to get in or out as we filmed
two ambulances came out of the red zone
the paramedics in this one were wearing
full-body protective suits
just a few hours drive away from here
our popular French ski resorts like
chemin e I worry a lot but I try to you
know probably they're not asking be
careful no I want to make sure that we
kind of assist with public health
efforts to avoid a spread but I don't
feel personally respected in Switzerland
the World Health Organization is leading
the fight against the virus the lesson
is that every country has to be ready
every country has to invest heavily in
their health systems
so whenever virus comes they can quickly
detect tests and provide health care for
those who are sick delegations come here
from around the world to seek advice
among the visitors the British former
health secretary the truth is the
Schengen or no Schengen we are in such a
globalized world as you can see by the
way it's spread that everyone has to
take precautions even though the
mortality rate of one to three percent
sounds low if millions and millions of
people get this virus that is our loss
of deaths and so that's why we have to
prepare for worst-case scenarios
Europe's response was calm and measured
but nobody could have predicted the
restrictions that would soon follow the
epidemic spread rapidly to other
countries with France Germany Spain and
the UK all recording sharp rises in
cases some of Spain's first cases were
recorded in the Canary Islands this
hotel in Tenerife can find guests to
their rooms
after a couple from northern Italy
tested positive for the virus a letter
was slipped under our door before we
woke up that's all we know it said that
we weren't allowed to leave the room for
medical reasons or something medical
tents were put in place outside hotel
reception with doctors ready to respond
the NHS subsequently issued new guidance
to people if people come back from
northern Italy and they subsequently in
the next 14 days get symptoms we
recommend that they self isolate
and then phone one one one well that was
Britain's approach other countries
reacted differently Italy went into a
full-scale lockdown police outnumber the
public on the streets of Rome anyone
passing needed a Paris and a reason why
the enforcement was calm and compliant
but the cracks appeared quickly more
Gomorrah actor Luca Franzese posted this
video of his dead sister in bed in the
background this cue for a supermarket
shows how seriously Italians took the
restrictions the director of intensive
care and Lombardi the worst hit region
describes the pressure and knowing what
you know now what would be your message
to other countries other health care
systems get ready because when it starts
then it's again like an explosion
Italy's Prime Minister has announced a
25 billion euro fund to spend on this
crisis but it has already cost the
country hugely the head of Italy's
emergency planning admits that they
acted too late
these measures they come slowly because
all the country have to be somehow
brought to this kind of measure is the
lockdown going to be extended the
lockdown will will stay as long as it is
not necessary
while Italy was in lockdown no such
measures had been put in place in
Britain but the virus was already here
after first emerging in China the virus
moved rapidly and silently and it was
beginning to spread in Britain in the
first few weeks the infection came from
half a dozen countries from China Japan
Singapore Iran and then closer to home
from Italy the Canary Islands and France
the first confirmed UK case was in York
on January 30th from China a so called
super spreader tested positive in
Brighton on February 6th and in the
early part of the month the spread
appeared minimal until by the end of
February 23 cases were confirmed by
March 2/3 it had doubled to 51 then it
trebled to 163 the first death on
British soil occurred at the Royal
Berkshire Hospital in Redding at the
start of March the advice remained to
wash your hands for 20 seconds the Prime
Minister put forward a 46 million pound
package for scientific efforts towards a
vaccine but it won't be ready to halt
this outbreak it looks to me as though
there will certainly be a substantial
period of disruption when we have to
deal with this with this outbreak how
big that will be how long that will be I
think it's still an open question but
clearly it is something we're going to
have to deal with for quite a while here
in the in the UK as it turned out it was
only a matter of days before the virus
started to impact every aspect of
British life
the first big business casualty in the
UK was the regional airline fly B which
had already been struggling it collapsed
putting 2,000 jobs at risk the impact of
coronavirus on air travel was the final
straw we really tried to do everything
that we possibly could back at the turn
of the air
and unfortunately though with the
situation has developed with the corona
an already weak company I'm afraid just
hasn't been able to survive in London
extra cleaning of public transport was
ordered to come back the virus but
everywhere felt quieter than normal
well this is region Street normally
bustling the beating heart of central
London as you can see it's extremely
quiet
no wonder business leaders are worried
the restaurant sector has already seen a
massive drop in the number of customers
coming through its doors
Sankara law is one of the most
successful restaurant groups in Britain
buying 1,100 people with the turnover of
around the hundred million pounds a year
although Zilly has been in this business
all his life but can't remember a
challenge like this we don't know what's
going to happen
we're fighting a battle we we're at war
with with with no one to fight so we
don't know we fighting it's it's quite
obscure you know in my opinion after 45
years in the business in this country I
I don't know I don't remember anything
similar my lovin over a father see Carlo
de Stefano founded this business and
acknowledges these are worrying times I
mean it could happen in ten thousands -
entity really shocking with that and
some time and Europe in the morning
I think it's lacking by the gym you know
I fought to stop because this job is
crazy I mean yesterday was dead so they
look like they got to be dead again
people can throw when the phone rings
cancel cancel cancel cancel so it's very
in London very very bad
it's about staying positive is about
staying open if we can if they don't
close us you know because they might
just say like Spain and Italy and France
you know what we have to do it we have
to listen but going forwards you know
it's it's a it's a lottery we have to we
have to stay positive and keep our
customers as safe as possible
Ireland's government decided to shut all
schools colleges and universities for at
least two weeks I just hope it doesn't
go on for so long cuz it's the panic has
really set in my parents right now the
kids are gonna be flying yeah they're
gonna be bored after heads and the
mommies will probably kill because
they're they're gonna be driven wild we
sent home initially work for the boys to
do what teachers can kind of add to that
as the time goes on so they like it's
not a major work that's been sent home
it's it's worth - we'll keep the kids
occupied supermarket shelves quickly
began to empty in Dublin and then came
the decision to shut all pubs bars and
restaurants until the end of March it
was unprecedented at this dublin pub the
owner had to layoff his staff and closed
the premises like every other bar in the
country what we're looking at is we're
looking the closure of seven payers and
pubs you know around the country and
that's estimated to be fifty thousand
jobs that have been lost as of yesterday
so the impact of that is absolutely huge
and plus the additional jobs that'll be
lost through the guys who supply into
the pubs as well so you're looking at
wholesalers and then you guys deploying
product in as well so there's a massive
amount of job cuts from the air this was
the impact of the virus on central
London Trafalgar Square almost deserted
some roads empty other drivers
determined to carry on
[Music]
the Prime Minister vowed to give people
all the help they need yes this enemy
can be deadly but it is also beatable
this government will do whatever it
takes there was a promise of three
months help for people struggling with
their mortgages and a massive financial
warchest to assist business this
government will give you all the tools
you need to get through this we will do
whatever it takes
today I am making available an initial
330 billion pounds of guarantees
equivalent to 15 percent of our GDP that
means any business who needs access to
cash to pay their rent their salaries
suppliers or purchase stock will be able
to access a government backed loan or
credit on attractive terms and if demand
is greater than the initial three
hundred and thirty billion pounds I'm
making available today I will go further
and provide as much capacity as required
I said whatever it takes and I meant it
in the United States an even more rapid
financial response government checks
could be rolled out to citizens as early
as April we're looking at sending checks
to Americans immediately and what we've
heard from hardworking Americans many
companies have now shut down whether
it's bars or restaurants Americans need
cash now and the president wants to get
cash now and I mean now in the next two
weeks
[Music]
in France the whole country is now in
lockdown or a module power at this
moment and since last night
100,000 policemen are being deployed
throughout the country their missions
will be to make sure that each person
has their sign declaration if they go
out the nation of liberty and fraternity
has curbed the freedoms its people so
cherish queues at the supermarket but
people remain calm everyone to stay at
home because it's things to that that's
we cannot stop the the propagation of
the in this town center the florist gave
away his stock before the town's bells
signaled the start of the lockdown Italy
remains the worst-hit country in Europe
the crisis has not yet peaked here but
in Lombardi the health system is on its
knees at this hospital the laundry room
is being used to treat patients staff
working 18-hour shifts end up treating
their own colleagues as well a surgeon
in Bergamo gave this update on the
desperate situation and what would you
say to your colleagues in Europe
shortly Jolie's they would never think
could get for example oxygen and
personal protection devices are sold we
have two phases patience strong enough
to travel from Lombardi are being
brought by helicopter to other parts of
the country in just 10 days this
hospital in Rome has been turned into a
covert 19 facility with a hundred and
eighty beds
we're thinking in the space of a few
weeks this virus has spread and spread
we've seen how governments around the
world have reacted to it now we're
seeing how people are being forced to
change every aspect of their lives this
is a rapidly evolving situation and
nobody knows what is going to happen
next
but one thing is certain covered 19 has
changed 2020 beyond all recognition for
everyone everywhere
you